welcome back to 8701
so in this video we'll talk about the
nuclear shell model
we've already seen an interesting
empirical model to describe
nuclear binding energies the liquid drop
model
but it comes short in the description of
all aspects
of the nucleus so
let's see what we can find here first of
all
you probably remember shell models from
atomic physics and gel models are very
successful in describing hydrogen for
example
the question is can this also work for
the nucleus
after all the nucleus is a many body
system right compared to hydrogen where
you have a proton
and an electron circling around there's
no analytic solutions like the
schrodinger equation
there is no dominant center for
long-range force like the proton has
been the dominant center
um and short-range force forces with
many pairs of inter we have
short-range range forces with many pairs
of interacting and that can continue the
list of difficulties
on the other hand the interactions kind
of average out and result in a potential
which depends
only on the position but not on the time
timing of the nucleus and that leads us
then to what we call a nuclear mean
field so on
average our proton and our neutron
inside the nucleus
sees a specific potential and we can use
that then parameterize this potential
with a harmonic oscillator
and you know use that model then in
order to
describe our nucleus so this works
actually surprisingly well
but before we go there we look at
experimental evidence for
closed nuclear shells so again here's
our plot of the binding energy
and you see that there is those areas
here
there seem to be some sort of
higher binding energies and it turns out
those happen at
so-called magic numbers imagine numbers
are 2 8
20 28 50 126
um so the question now is how can we
explain this where does this come from
so again the experimental evidence is
numerous
we find that the number of stable
isotopes or isotones
is significantly higher for nuclei with
a proton
or neutron or both numbers equal to one
of those magic numbers
the nuclear capture cross section
meaning the the likelihood
to capture a proton or neutron are high
for nucleoids where
exactly one nucleon is missing from a
magic number
but it's significantly lower for nucleis
with numbers
of this number of nucleons equal to the
magic number
meaning that there is this concept of a
closed shelf you either just add a
nucleus
to close it or we have to pay a higher
price
the energy of excited states for nuclear
nuclei
with a proton or neutron number equal to
the magic number are significantly
higher than for other nuclei
so this are all experimental
observations
and the excitation probabilities of the
first excited states are low for nuclei
with a proton or neutron
or both numbers equal to the magic
minerals
quadrupole moments we haven't discussed
those at length but you can think about
them as deformations of the nuclei
[Music]
they almost vanish for nucleus with
proton or neutral numbers
equal to the magic numbers so those are
more kind of theory
kind of objects uh here's a plot which
shows
or points out the double magic numbers
those are
those are nucleus where both the proton
number
and the neutron number are lying on the
double
on the magic number so calcium here has
two of those
um with 20 protons and 20 neutrons
or 20 protons and 28 neutrons
and there's others those are
specifically interesting interesting
objects of research
there was some historic confusion in
this
and it came from the fact that while the
experimental data pointed to nuclear
magic numbers of 22
8 20 28 50 and under 26
if you just think about a flat bottom
potential just a flat
potential um you find magic numbers
which are 2a
20 40 70 and 112 and those are typically
not in
agreement so therefore you know
it seemed like that this shell model
kind of worked
but not really we found agreement here
but then disagreement in the higher part
of the magic numbers so something was
missing and so what was missing
was the spin orbit part of the
discussion
we alluded to this in the nuclear force
what you have to do is beyond a
three-dimensional
harmonic oscillator
you have to add the spin-orbit complex
to your hamiltonian
and when you do that you change the
orbit such that
the magic numbers agree with the
experimental
data so you see here the potentials
for proton which has also the column
repulsion added
and the nuclear potential and then you
see that you know the spin orbit
coupling
slightly changes the potential
all right as a comparison here the
nuclear and atomic shell models just for
an example and you see
we call them shells because you know we
see that the
you see that the energy gaps between
individual shells are quite large much
larger
um than than within the shell and the
same
this is for the atomic model and for the
nucleus
you see very similar so it's not that
extended but still
larger gaps and energy when you go from
one stage